[Applause]
it's time for the big goodbye we have
time for two questions so
denise from atlanta tweeted to us in
honor of world teachers day is there a
mentor or a teacher that has changed
your life that deserves a shout out
today you know i've always
chosen to follow people smarter than me
i feel like i have a very long line of
mentors and
one of my life's missions is to meet
them in that
wise field they're in one day but then
there are mentors who also
take care of us teach us about life and
give us opportunity
and for me that is steven spielberg i
know i wouldn't be standing here if it
wasn't for him
and he really gave me an opportunity in
my life that is just been mine not to
screw up and
respect that choice he made that day by
picking me for a film that would just
change everything as i know it so
thank you stephen he also took really
good care of me and is just the most
wonderful human being so he gets my
change my life mentorship not out not
out that doesn't even make sense
that isn't the word shout out and a nod
that's what a nod out is
it's the combo so let's go to our
beautiful
virtual friends hi friends can we bring
up mike from queens
hi guys hi mike hey
hey drew i really want to know what's
one of your favorite mementos you've
kept from film sets
over the years that is a fantastic
question mike thank you for asking it
uh i still have the cowgirl hat from e.t
when it's halloween and i'm in the
cowgirl outfit
i still have the hat and i just keep it
sort of hanging
out in my kid's bedroom